All right.
Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled peppers that works two one Jad,
Robert, Radiolab. And now we're going to do part two of our border patrol elegy.
A okay with reporter, a lot of Nasr. Uh,
in our last podcast we had part one of the series,
which we called hole in the fence. But let's the, I'm,
I'm excited to tell you now the rest of the story.
I feel like I'm holding out on you. Okay. And now part two, hold the line. Um,
so, so let's do first the,
the previously on I think instead of previously on is that, uh,
we had, so it was, uh, December 1st, 1992,
uh,
you have these Mexican American high school kids from this poor neighborhood,
this high school buoy high school in El Paso, right on the border.
They sue the border patrol. Who is, they say is harassing them,
who's hassling them because of really the color of their skin and they win.
They win. Is that amazing?
And probable a victory to get the border patrol to stop.
So that's where we are now. Right.
And things are about to take some unexpected turns. Okay. Uh,
uh, we're looking at the early 1990s.
The lawsuit was filed in 1992 and right after that lawsuit, you know,
pass according to Tim Dunn,
the sociologists who actually turned us onto this whole UE story right after the
buoy victory, the border patrol chief in El Paso, Dale,
Musa guedes obviously kind of old school
throwback. We're not accomplishing 100% of our mission. He's out.
Music AIDS is replaced and they bring in a new chief. Yes.
My name is Sylvester days and Sylvester a ray. Yes.
I've been a veteran of the US border patrol for 26 and a half years and he has a
very different style. Great spot here. Yeah.
This is one of my wife and i's favorite place. Where do you want me
here?
I met Sylvester Rayez in this Mexican restaurant on the outskirts of El Paso.
He's big guy, broad shoulders kind of look like a, um,
like a retired football player. But who is now a gram?
How are you? Merry Christmas. Merry Christmas.
Awesome coffee with green. Perfect.
You don't mind very kind face for a guy who revolutionized how we deal with the
border. You and you grew up here?
We're sitting here about a mile from where I was born. Yeah.
Our farm was northwest of here. We uh, we grew cotton.
Okay. Alfalfa, some watermelon, some onions.
I'm the oldest of 10 oh six brothers and four sisters. Yeah.
He says that his brothers and sisters,
they all work on the farm along with a bunch of undocumented workers who came in
from Juarez back then we had party line foams. So somebody would say a,
the burritos coming today, but they didn't know what time or where.
So whenever that happened, uh,
I was tasked to sit in a two and a half ton truck and he would watch the road
and I would blow the
horn
at the first sign of what we would refer to as La Miga.
[inaudible] to alert the workers. Yeah.
He actually calls it the greatest irony of his life because fast forward to
college, I got drafted into the army.
He gets drafted to go to Vietnam and spent 13 months in Vietnam.
I was a helicopter crew chief. When I came back from Vietnam,
I was scheduled to go back.
But what happened in 1968 was my second brother,
he had an automobile accident and got killed.
So I was the oldest in the family.
So they led me out to take care of the family.
And so ray as needed, a job being a veteran,
any federal exam they opened up for you.
So he starts taking these federal job exams, the post office, Bureau of Prisons,
customs, border patrol.
I mean just any tests that I could cause I had to make a living and the very
first place to call him back. Border Patrol?
No. Oh yeah. That was what was available. Again, Tim Dunn, you.
So he becomes a kind of pioneer a in the border patrol is one of the early
Hispanic agents. When there were very few,
the job was tough cause they didn't welcome you with open arms because your name
is Reyes and not Smith or Jones. But I kind of enjoyed the challenge.
You thought he was dead set and do everything twice as good and half the time.
And eventually he moves from being an agent into management and he works his way
up through management. I was a first line supervisor through the rank,
second line supervisor taught at the academy and he eventually becomes the first
Hispanic sector chief, which means he's in charge of it. Huge
swath of the border in Texas. Yeah.
So then come 1993 you are a sector chief and you're assigned back here,
right. I was moved here in late June and uh, uh,
in early July I decided to assess the situation and the situation in El Paso did
not look good.
No, the sector was a mess.
So one of the first things ray has discovered is that
the border between the u s and Mexico, a Paseo is in a state of chaos.
Chaos. We were averaging about 10,000 illegal, increased a day,
a day, a day, unprecedented numbers,
and we're troll didn't have enough people to get them off.
So people were telling me that agents are pretty much regularly stopping El Paso
Pasoans running ramshackle through the city,
driving around the neighborhoods and questioning everybody, stopping people,
asking for their immigration status,
and they're doing this despite the fact that they just got sued by these high
school kids for doing essentially the same thing.
And this lawsuit is still hanging over the patrol. How big a deal was that?
There was a huge deal. It was making a chaotic situation worse.
And Rhea says, on top of all of this, there was a movement when I got here
to push the border patrol out,
that the border should be moved 25 miles out of the city to kind of create a
borderless zone around the city to unite El Paso and Juarez.
It was kind of in the spirit of NAFTA opening up NAFTA is good for us because it
will cut the tariffs on trade between the United States and Mexico,
the North American free trade agreement.
NAFTA is going to open the border for the flows of goods and capital, uh,
but not people. And they're saying, well, how about right here?
A little bit for people too.
So they felt that the border patrol is an invading army.
They're the problem instead of the solution. Yeah.
So what do you find is that they're really unpopular and that's just half the
reason they're unpopular.
There's a whole bunch of other people that hate them for a whole different
reason. Really. Yeah. He, he, when he got there, he went on this listening,
walking tour of the neighborhoods along the border. There's,
there's whole neighborhoods there like Chewa Weeta and El Segundo Barrio.
I walked those neighborhoods and I talked to them and uh,
they thought the border patrol was a disaster.
But instead of saying that the border patrol was overreaching,
that they were doing too much, they felt that the border patrol had failed him.
They were upset. The border patrol was not doing enough, had let them down.
And the people that lived on those neighborhoods,
they felt like they were under siege.
We have been broken away three times by illegal immigrants,
although grown scared
people complained about burglaries, about loitering,
people selling their fruits and knocking on doors, asking for money.
They didn't like have to deal with vendors all the time or people begging and
they didn't like having stuff stolen off their backyard, a garden hose,
a lawn chair, stuff stolen off their clothes online gone overnight.
And so with these people living right on the border one and was more border
patrol to stop what they perceive to be, you know, migrant petty crime. Huh?
Susie? He's really getting it from both sides here. Yeah.
It's like the whole city's coming at them.
We were with one foot on a banana peel of getting driven out of town.
Yeah. And so I had to change that and I didn't have a lot of time to do that.
Okay. So, so what does he do? Well, he had an idea,
a pretty radical idea. I knew there would be political pressure,
there would be public outcry.
And so he takes this idea around to a bunch of high level people.
The mirror flood is the mayor of El Paso,
people at the Mexican console in El Paso. Our console in quarters,
the sheriff and El Paso, chief of police of what is in El Paso.
And he's going each one of them and basically saying, look,
if we're able to correct this thing, if I can quell the chaos,
would they support the border patrol?
You said? Yes.
Okay. So here's what I find so fascinating.
It's September of 93 and while Reyes is hatching his plan at the same time at
the El Paso Civic Center on this one particular weekend,
the United El Paso people are having this big convention talking about how we
can try and create this,
borderless all sorts of local officials and civic leaders there in hammering out
their proposals and everything and presenting it to the audience.
And that same weekend,
Sylvester Rayez rolls out his plan. He wanted this to be a surprise.
So we launched the operation at midnight. So it's September 18th,
1993 Saturday night, Rayez gathers all of his border patrol agents,
400 border patrol agents from all over his sector.
And I briefed every single shift of agents myself and I told him what was at
stake. I told him that if this thing didn't work,
they were going to run us out of town.
My initial reaction was, well, this is going to be interesting.
Retired border patrol agent David Ham was there with his anti-drug smuggling
unit and he says, after the briefing,
we drove up the border highway on the Mexican side and we got to a downtown
waters and the Levy area about sunrise.
And so he and his agents are waiting right at the Rio Grande.
The Sun came up and he said there at the border,
he just saw wall-to-wall border patrol,
a wall of agents along the river, a hundred yards apart,
each one in their trucks, light green trucks.
There were helicopters buzzing low along the river.
There were flood lights everywhere so the agents could be out there around the
clock 24 hours a day.
Basically what ray has had done is he had created a human wall on the border at
the river that stretched for like 20 miles. Wow.
And I had told my guys, we're in this for the long haul.
What Reyes was doing, this was,
this plan was to essentially change our strategy on the border,
how we police the border from a strategy of apprehension of letting migrants
come in and running around, chasing them,
sending them back to one of deterrence and he called it
Operation Blockade Operation Blockade.
[inaudible]
day one on Sunday morning like they always did, hundreds of Mexican migrants,
vendors, construction workers,
housekeepers came down to the Rio Grande River waiting to cross into El Paso for
work,
but now they were confronted with the Berlin Wall on the border,
border patrol agents lining the entire river bank on the line where they would
have to wait them out waiting to see when the border patrol agents will pack up
and leave. By the time night falls, the migrants,
they just turn and go home and figure, okay,
I guess so we'll just come back in the morning.
They came back Monday and we were still there and that's when this starts to get
chaotic. Day Two sevenths.
Amy Jacobson is standing by live under the Paso del Norte in bridge where the
incident occurred.
Hundreds of Mexicans took to the main bridge that connects El Paso and Juarez
and estimated 800 Mexican protestors
close the [inaudible] bridge and confronted water patrol. They burnt tires.
They blockaded traffic again, throwing rocks and bottles. Agents.
There were skirmishes. One agent was struck in the face with a rock,
blood and bandages. Still literally the area, no,
by that time there was screaming going on is a racist,
tormenting racism. There are all these headlines in the newspaper.
There are better ways to do this. Basically saying this, this new strategy,
this is wrong.
Operation Blockade is nothing more than an attempt to divide the community race
as the mayor of El Paso who he briefed about the operation is denying ever
knowing about it. So I called him and I said, mayor, he says, chief,
I just didn't know what to do.
How many children are going hungry because their parents cannot come to El Paso
to work. The local bishop came out and criticized rates.
You said it was inhumane to do what I was doing.
How many will suffer close this winter if the blockade continues and this is the
only date to have the blockade by by day three long have around 200 occupied the
of Deloitte things continue to get worse day. Four more protests. Day Five, six,
seven. At the end of the week, people were starting to get really desperate,
but a remarkable thing happened that I didn't plan for
the banners on private property or out to show support for Operation Blockade.
The support for the [inaudible]
skyrocketed. They're out there support enforcing the laws. People that live in
done those neighborhoods that felt like they were under siege and the Bordeaux
had failed them. They came out with these huge banners of,
we support our border patrol. They tied ribbons on their cars.
They came out with donuts and coffee for the border patrol agents who are on the
line. It was like all of a sudden there was this sort of flip.
People locally all loved it across racial and ethnic lines.
Mov Stowe, [inaudible]
over time. What happened during this blockade with two things. One.
We've seen it reduce crime is one of the most popular reasons these El Paso
winds are in favor of operation blockade. Crime goes down.
Now it's hard to tell whether this is actually because of the blockade,
but there's a reduction in petty crime,
a something like 15% for the local residents. That's the bottom line.
And the second thing, and this is way more surprising,
was that for Mexican Americans who had been harassed by the border patrol
presence in their neighborhoods,
they start to notice that you just don't see the agents anymore.
The agents were gone, right? Right.
It completely cleared them out because now they were all down on the border.
So there's this, you know, this tidal wave of support,
like virtually everybody locally and El Paso,
both sides are really happy with what he's doing.
He seemed to solve the problem in one fell swoop.
What was the reaction at buoy high school? The principal called me. Yeah,
Paul Strelzin was his name. He's passed away now. Uh, he called me and he said,
uh, chief, I hope you, I hope you thought this out because you are,
you have us our campus back
[inaudible]
but right in the midst of all of this,
so visceral Rayez gets a phone call,
a phone call from Washington d c saying, you've got to stop this.
[inaudible]
we'll tell you all about that phone call
and what falls out of that call after the break.
[inaudible]
hi, this is Adam McBride from the pork Colorado.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
this next part of the episode contains some moments that are very graphic that
depict death in a pretty brutal way.
If you're squeamish or you're listening with kids, maybe Trump,
maybe you think about skipping this bar.
Jad Robert Radiolab. This is part two of our border patrol, LG, a firm report.
A lot of Nasr. When we left the story,
so Vista Reyes had put into place operation blockade,
which was then renamed operation hold the line.
And everyone in El Paso seemed happy. Very happy.
Yeah. But people in Washington,
D C we're not because the Clinton administration,
they're about to have this vote on NAFTA. They're talking about free trade.
And then this guy, this little guy in El Paso,
he's created a blockade and a,
it's looking like it's gonna be a little closer than they thought.
And the last thing the Clinton administration needs is any controversy over
this. And so right in the middle of operation blockade,
Rayez gets a phone call from his boss's boss's boss. So your Magenta, Reno,
no, Janet Reno, who is the attorney general, was a big lady. Very imposed.
I like her. I mean even back then when she was hammering away at me,
I liked her and she wanted to talk to me and she started using talking points.
Why it was a wrong thing. Yeah. Political consequences,
international ramification, blah, blah, blah. He has this sense, okay, I'm,
I'm uh, I'm about to be fired. Oh yeah. But he says to her, I said,
Madam Attorney General, with all due respect, do me one favor. I said,
come and visit El Paso. Just come and visit El Pestle. Yeah. He said,
because you are making these statements with all due respect,
without knowing the, that it's made
in El Paso. I said, please come to El Paso.
She silence. And I said, Oh crap.
But she says I will be there Tuesday.
[inaudible]
so Janet Reno flies to El Paso. Rayez sets up a bunch of meetings for her.
And I told her, I said, look,
I'm not going to be there cause I want you to hear it unfiltered and without me
being there as he tells it,
Janet Reno sat down for all these meetings with all these local business people
and she was so blown away by what she heard,
how happy everyone was with the situation.
Then she put aside the fact that Mexico was best put aside NAFTA. Yeah.
And uh, she came back and she, she shook my hand.
[inaudible]
very impressive. What you've done here is amazing.
What people are telling me is incredible. I mean, she went on and on. She says,
I'm going back and I'm going to tell the president that he needs to hear you
talk about this operation. Wow. I said the prison of the United States, yes.
Cheat your entire view after after one visit. That's what he says.
And apparently she was barely there for a day. Let,
I wish we could get Janet Reno's take on this,
but unfortunately she died in 2016 but her change of heart actually makes a
certain kind of sense. I mean there was a real, a very important um,
political element to all of this. That's Doris Meissner.
She was at the time the head of the Immigration and Naturalization Service.
Basically.
Janet Reno is number two when it came to the border and she says that at that
moment the Janet Reno was in Texas touring El Paso.
The Clinton administration had a big problem on his hands because about a
thousand miles west, Californians are
up in arms about the illegal immigration.
But as coming into California,
we're 40% of the babies born on Medicaid in California today are born of illegal
immigrants going according to the centers, the blender finish. I agree.
We are going to take back California. You had this wave.
Do you like American of anti immigrant sentiment and initiatives like
proposition one 87 proposition one 87 attempts to solve the state illegal
immigration problem by denying services to illegal immigrants.
Super hard line measure measure past five 59% of the state's votes by a wide
margin. And the Clinton administration was definitely paying attention because
California is California.
The largest electoral college prize in November is presidential election.
And keep in mind,
California had been a red state from 1968 all the way to 1992 Clinton was the
guy who broke the cycle and if he was going to get reelected,
California had to continue to vote for the Clinton administration
[inaudible]
so one of the things that might have changed, Janet Reno's mind,
or more importantly her boss, Bill Clinton's mind,
was that saw in El Paso a potential solution to the California problem.
If they could make illegal immigration way less visible as ray as had done in El
Paso,
maybe they could hold to stay.
I'm pleased to be here today with the INS commissioner, Doris Meissner,
February 7th, 1995 and special heroes mine.
Chief Sylvester Reyes of the El Paso Border Patrol.
We have just come from a meeting with President Clinton,
which time he signed a presidential memorandum directing our agencies to move
forward with new initiatives to gain control of our border and better enforce
our immigration laws. This is the first
national border patrol strategy. That's right.
I spend a great deal of time on it.
Things had not been done that way before and it was a,
it was a fundamental change in strategy
according to Doris Meissner and she really was the architect of this strategy.
The idea was to take what ray is, was doing,
which was very clarifying and scale it up.
There were basically four major crossing corridors along the southwest border.
Each of those four spots that we're going to amass border patrol agents on the
border, not behind the border, not in the city where they piss off the locals,
but directly on the border concentrate resources starting of course in
California,
our strategy was to start in San Diego because that was the highest crossing
corridor,
maybe 45 to 50% of the crossings across the entire southwest border were
happening in the San Diego sector.
We start in San Diego with operation gatekeeper.
That's what that one was called.
We then moved to I believe Arizona and I'm just trying to think of what we named
that operation safeguard. Safeguard. That was right. Exactly.
And then the fourth was south Texas.
All of a sudden now in 1994, the Border Patrol, uh, publishes this,
what's called the, um, the strategic plan,
also known as prevention through deterrence. This is Jason De Leon again,
the anthropologist who started us off on this whole series that they write in
this policy document.
We know the border cuts across a whole bunch of very difficult environments.
If we disrupt a traditional crossing places, urban ports of entry.
And we push people towards these extreme environments.
They will have to cross rushing rivers, mountainous terrain,
places that where you can freeze to death, where you can die of dehydration.
But the extreme environment, we'll slow people's movement,
will make them easier to catch and will also perhaps stop them from coming.
In other words, after Rayez,
it became our national strategy to push people away from urban areas and use,
say the desert as a kind of natural deterrent. The
thinking was that that would be a natural geographic, you know,
uh,
ally that would take care of the rest.
No.
And
now one of the things of course, that we learn is that,
um, that that didn't hold
because in the 90s, the Mexican economy was struggling,
so people still needed jobs and that on the American side,
farms and businesses were still happy to hire them. So people still crossed,
except now they weren't crossing through the cities.
They were crossing through the desert where no one was watching.
Five men stumbled out of the mountain pass. So sun struck.
They didn't know their own names. Just like in new Rayez book,
the Devil's highway, couldn't remember where they'd come from.
[inaudible]
had forgotten and how long they'd been lost.
And so that's why in the late nineties you see the number of people dying in the
Sonoran desert overnight start to skyrocket.
You go from five to 10 bodies to to hundreds
by 2002 or so the numbers in Arizona, our upper end, 150 deaths per year,
a couple of years after that, it goes over 200.
Those are the official border patrol numbers that they report based on the
number of bodies found.
But after Jason had that experience finding an arm in the desert and not being
able to locate the rest of the body, he,
he started to wonder whether those numbers were accurate or not.
How many more people might be dying out there who are never found,
never counted. Yeah.
Which for Jason at least became a scientific question about what happens to
bodies in the desert. How fast do they decompose? And what ends up happening is,
um, I just kind of hit the library, scour the literature. You know,
there's body farms where we do this with Tennessee, Texas.
Jason found this one paper that suggested that when bodies are decomposing in
the desert, the heat and the dryness can drastically slow that process down.
This idea that the desert is going to conserve a body that's gonna mummify and
that people will be out there forever according to that paper,
could take up to six months for a body to decompose to the point where you'd be
able to see the bones. Wow.
But the remains in that study were collected in a bunch of different areas under
different conditions, sometimes even indoors.
No one had done it kind of in C2 in the desert. We had literally no,
no scientific data on that at all.
And so I started getting really interested in,
is there a way to do some, some science around this?
He eventually wrote in and an assistant named Kate Hall Hall.
And I'm a physical. Yes.
Just what's a physical anthropologist?
I'm a physical anthropologist is someone who studies,
they re they study human bones and they try and infer what someone's life and
death was like from skeletal remains.
And Jason Pretty much came up to me and told me that he'd been thinking about
getting some pigs, pigs, pigs,
pigs have long been the common proxy for human bodies, you know,
for crime scene stuff like, um, they would, they shoot him,
they bury them and they, you know, they,
and they use them for these different are sort of, um,
decomposition experiments. So,
uh, Jason and Kate and the research team had down to Arizona,
University of Arizona has a meat laboratory that's,
that deals with live animals. So we called up, uh, uh, Jerome, the,
uh, pig euthanize her and he came out in this big truck.
He comes out with these animals to pigs 150 pounds each alive.
Jerome shoots the pigs in the head right in front of them.
And then Kate and Jason, we got shoes and socks dressed their pigs, bra,
panties, jeans,
tee shirts and clothes that migrants would wear because they wanted to recreate
the conditions. Exactly.
And then they took these dress dead pigs out into the desert.
Arivaca Arizona.
It's like another planet. It's like nowhere else I have ever been on earth.
Um, it's hot and saying it's hot.
It doesn't really do it justice. It was like hundred,
1,015 degrees Fahrenheit. Whoa.
So Jason and the research team get together in this big field and we had one one
pig under a tree in light shade.
We were trying to replicate like if someone was tired and needed to take a rest
somewhere and for the second pig, Jason had heard from anecdotes, from migrants,
stories about people dying in their groups and they would say,
well we didn't want to leave this person behind,
but we had to because they were dead.
They would cover their body with rocks and hopes of protecting them from
animals. So they placed these two pigs, one in the shade,
one under rocks in the sun, and they set up a series of motion sensing cameras.
Yeah,
all around the perimeter of the area to watch both pigs.
These are the kinds of cameras that turn on if something moves. Right.
We set up the cameras under a very, very hot sun. And then they waited.
And remember, based on what Jason had read,
the prevailing idea was that bodies in the desert don't decompose until,
you know, six months in to around nine months in.
And that would make the likelihood that they'd be found higher,
which might suggest that the official numbers are accurate. Regardless.
The assumption was that these bodies would be laying around for a while,
but pretty quick.
Okay.
Something moves and triggers the camera.
So this is footage of the pig that was in the shade.
And on the cameras you see this pig just under a tree lying on its side.
It's wearing his little white shoes. It has jeans on. It's bloated,
but it's intact.
And then later that night camera comes on again. It's night vision. Um,
you can see
the pig again and then,
yeah,
you see this vulture
[inaudible]
a few feet away from the pig kind of looking at it, kind of checking it out,
just standing there.
And then after a couple of hours,
camera comes back on and the other eight vultures on top of this pig packing and
tearing. A few hours later
they, they go in, they make a hole in the back of the neck, um,
kind of like kind of right behind the ear and they're trying to get at the brain
and then
they pull off the shirt.
They eventually ripped the jeans off.
By noon is the fifth day.
There are hordes of vultures.
You see them attack the abdomen,
ripped open the stomach and then you see intestines being pulled out and then
you have two vultures come in front of the camera and they're playing tug of war
with these intestines and they start to take apart the limbs.
They'll actually like carry them away.
They'll carry limbs as like convenient packages of meat that they can eat later
on day seven,
they dragged what was left to the body about 20 meters up a hill and within nine
days they had picnic, picked it clean.
Everything has been pulled apart and just scattered all over the place.
After nine days, this, there was hardly anything left. Nine days. Yeah.
So they thought it might take nine months and now it's down to nine days.
[inaudible] and that was the pig in the shade. The pig in the little rock hut.
The, that pig went way faster. Yeah. That was within 24 hours.
Vultures had started feeding and just got in underneath the rocks and rip that
up because we've, we had really forgotten that that rocks, um, conduct heat.
So it literally cooks the body and speeds up this process.
It w w completely defied expectations.
This wasn't all you're expecting at all.
And were, were vultures, the only scavengers that you are known as saying,
not the only scavengers. So we saw some ravens,
domestic dogs. Oh. So this town of Arivaca where we work in,
a lot of people die nearby and they have these, you know,
kind of ranch dogs that are pretty wide ranging and people have,
I've heard stories of people saying, you know, my doc at home with a,
with a piece of, uh, human bone. Um, uh, but these animals were, you know,
were on our property eating these pigs.
I'm just now thinking of it from the point of view of the dog owner.
I like this dog comes in and gets on the couch and like lifts your face.
That's the same tongue that might've been gnawing on a human arm. Exactly.
And after the vultures and crows and dogs that have their way with these pigs,
Jason k told us that the desert started working in smaller almost invisible
ways. I
had never seen this before. Like we're used to flies and some beetles,
but we have footage of aunts and consuming parts of long bones.
They're chipping off pieces of bone and carrying them off to this ant hole a
meter away.
That was really shocking and it kind of hinted to the fact that you leave
someone out there for long enough and they will completely disappear.
This is an environment in which people can become really easily just erased.
Well there is something about when you,
when you were describing the first moment when the vultures really sort of tear
into the body. I, I found myself kind of recoiling trying to protect my abdomen.
I still have that reaction.
There's something just so overwhelmingly human about this.
You can't not take this personally. Well,
can we talk about the, uh, the numbers for a second?
Because if bodies are decomposing and disappearing this fast,
those border patrol numbers start to look suspiciously low.
Do you have any sense based on the speed of the decomposition,
how many people we might have
the missing? Well, you know, it just, it just depends. I mean, on the,
on when people die at what time of year, I mean, if you live,
I guess a better way to do it is if you compare the number of missing persons
reports with the numbers of recovered bodies, there's a discrepancy of,
of thousands. These are missing persons reports from,
these are people leaving from Latin America and missing persons reports are
either filed in the u s by families already here or,
or from these sending countries, but thousands of missing persons reports, um,
more than the actual recovered bodies. Thousands a year.
Thousands of people go missing a year during this process.
Starting obviously missing persons reports don't equate to deaths in the desert.
But pretty much everyone I talk to, including some retired border patrol agents,
agree that the official number is an under count. Now,
when it comes to the actual number of deaths, nobody knows for sure.
Depending on who you ask,
the real number could be anywhere from twice to 10 times the official count,
and if you think about the fact that that has been happening for 20 years,
then what that high school history teacher one cyber corn auto told us at the
end of our last episode doesn't sound so crazy
because of us fences were built because the fences were built.
Maybe 10,000 people have died in the desert.
Yeah, and there's no way to verify that number or any number,
but the potential scale of it kind of forces you to ask who is responsible.
Some of these people I've talked to said that the Mexican government needs to do
more to stop people going into these areas, which seems like a bit of a cop out.
A others blame the smugglers who bring people over.
Some people have said that the migrants, it's their responsibility.
They knew they were making this decision to come. If they die, it's on them,
but the other obvious question is what about us?
Yeah, and what's clear, you know,
according to Jason is that US policy makers weren't exactly clueless about this
and there were points where people were saying things like, if we do this,
if we funnel them towards the Sonora desert of Arizona,
we funnel them towards the sort of backwoods of Texas.
People are going to get hurt, people are going to die. But if enough people die,
perhaps that will be the determinant then that they'll stop coming and there are
the charts. Is that written down that if, oh my God, yeah,
the death equals deterrence.
There's a chart that I cite in the book and this was one of the,
one of the moments where I was,
when I was doing the kind of archival research that just just shocked me where
there was a point where someone had written this policy document.
And then in one of the followup reports by the government accountability office,
some number cruncher or some policy maker is sitting at a computer and DC making
an excel chart where they're putting out different metrics to measure the
effectiveness of this policy. And one of the metrics is an increase in, in um,
in migraine death.
So there was a recognition that if death goes up it means that this policy is
working. I ended up finding the document Jason was referring to. It's a,
it's a report from the Government Accountability Office from 1997.
And I talked to Doris Meissner about it. She's remember the, uh,
former INS commissioner that helped take Sylvester Rayez is hold the line
strategy national. I actually read part of the report to her. Yes.
And then there was this kind of one appendix in it.
So it's called appendix five.
And it's a indicators for measuring the effectiveness of the strategy to deter
illegal entry along the southwest borders. And one of the indicators was deaths,
deaths of aliens attempting entry. Um, and basically what it says is that,
um, I'm sort of quoting it that if the attorney general strategy is successful,
deaths may increase as enforcement in urban areas forces aliens to attempt
mountain or desert crossings. In effect saying that if this strategy,
if if deaths increase in these treacherous areas,
that's a sign that the strategy is working.
I do. I
think I recall reading that because it's so, you know,
it makes you gasp when you have to really think about what the,
all of the implications of all of these things are. I mean, you know,
this is one of the paradoxes of how is it that you go about doing work like
this.
It's absolutely clear for so many reasons that there needs to be border
security.
But I think it is fair to say that the idea that we had at the time and thinking
that we put into place at the time was two simple,
what
was much more difficult to take into account.
It has been the tenacity of people coming to the United States wanting to come
to the United States and the length to which people will go in order to do that.
What, but there's another way to read this. I mean the uh, the appendix five,
that's sort of the, the thing that, that as you, in your words you said,
you know,
could make you gasp with that sort of says in one way to read that is that we
took, um,
a problem that was very visible and we pushed it to places where we can't see it
anymore.
And we did that with full knowledge that, that,
that people dying means we're doing the right thing to, to me,
appendix five begs the question, I mean, what responsibility do we,
I have for this?
It doesn't quite feel like this is something that we can just shrug and say,
we didn't know this is going to happen.
It feels like we knew damn well this is going to happen.
Um, you know, when you asked the question, what is our responsibility?
And when you say our, I think,
and I take that to mean what is our responsibility as a nation?
The answer at the time,
and the answer still is that the enforcement will do everything that it can to
prevent people from crossing in dangerous areas,
but that cannot include no longer doing enforcement across the border.
Now Doris says that, you know,
once they started to realize these numbers had spiked in that people were going
through these areas, they started doing a lot of public awareness campaigns,
campaigns,
warning people about the dangers of the desert efforts devoted to safety on the
Mexican side. And they created a whole new search and rescue unit.
So there were all kinds of efforts to address it.
But I will be absolutely frank with you.
The idea of abandoning any kind of strengthened border enforcement because of
that consequence was not a serious, I have not a point of serious discussion
and the policy never really changed in any substantive way. There was a,
there was a later report that came out from the government accountability office
in 2006 that basically said, you look, you've done all these safety measures,
but the deaths in the desert are still going up.
Doris Meisner was no longer head of the ins at that point,
but after reaching out to a whole bunch of people who wrote that report and the
people who received it and hearing nothing back, frankly,
I finally got in touch with the commissioner of Customs and Border Protection
under President Bush at the time.
Ralph Basham now retired and he told me he remembered reading that report.
He said that he thought about those deaths all the time every day,
but in the end he said it was just politically infeasible to back off the
enforcement at the major crossing points or to get enough border patrol to
really control dangerous areas like the desert. And in the end,
the u s government didn't make any substantive changes in response to the rise
in deaths.
And I guess you could read that as a lack of political will or indifference.
But Jason actually argues that we were giving a sort of tacit blessing to this
system that was killing all these people because it kept this problem just swept
under the rug. Yeah. Um,
are you saying that the u s government or whatever portion of it is responsible
for this policy is knowingly, um,
killing people?
I would say it's knowingly putting people in harms way and they know that there
is a high likelihood that a certain percentage of people are going to die and
have been dying. So it's like, so it's like they're having nature do the,
do their dirty work. That's kind of what you feel like is absolutely, I mean,
I would say 100% that nature is an agent of the border patrol. Um, it's a,
this kind of unsung hero of the border patrol. You know,
they're not on the payroll, but they do all this work.
The environment beats up on migrants. And then those who don't make it, it just,
it cleans up the mess as well.
And nobody has to be accountable for this because it just disappears.
We asked customs and border protection,
which overseas border patrol to comment whether they had tried to change their
strategy to avoid migrant deaths and they declined to answer.
I wonder if, I wonder if you feel somehow ambivalent about it.
Like obviously there are trade offs for everything. Every,
every plan has unintended consequences, but, but this,
now this has happened and, and these deaths are, are also happening. Um,
I wonder how you feel about it if you feel somehow ambivalent about it.
I feel deeply ambivalent about it. I feel deeply sorry about it.
I am very conflicted about it.
I also know that migration is by its very nature,
an incredibly dangerous enterprise. You know, when it's illegal immigration,
people coming up well before they ever get to the u s border.
People coming up through Mexico through very dangerous areas where they are
robbed and kidnapped and extorted. I mean, there are awful,
terrible things that go on in this quest for a better life.
What I wish is that we would be able as a country to put immigration policies
into effect,
that it actually allow for people to come here legally whom our economy is
asking for in terms of the jobs that exist in the country.
This system that we've been involved with for now decades of
allowing illegal immigration to occur in sizable numbers,
having worked for people in this is indefensible and the enforcement agencies
are caught in between that.
They're required to create border security and yet there are these terrible
costs.
Those terrible costs would not be there if we as a country and as a political
system would come to grips with the issue that is right in front of our eyes and
that we simply won't come together politically to answer that we are a nation of
immigrants. We are a country that believes in the rule of law.
We can't.
It is indefensible in light of that history and those values to have allowed
this kind of an illegal immigration picture to go on in the way that it has for
all these many years.
Wouldn't a wall, I mean it's,
this is going to sound [inaudible] misses an intentionally naive question,
but if what you're saying is that, uh, that, that uh,
we need to save lives, whether,
however you feel about the issue of immigration w isn't a wall more humane given
what you've just told us?
Well, the wall is not going to do anything. I mean we know that, you know,
I spend a lot of time now,
most of my time is not spent with smugglers who love the idea of a wall cause
they're like, man, I can charge twice as much for this,
for my services even though it's really not going to be that much harder.
I mean, cause people dig underneath it, they crawl over it, they fly over it,
they take a boat around it. I mean the wall itself is Never gonna.
It's never going to be a deterrent.
[inaudible]
and on top of that, I actually, I didn't even know this when we talked to Jason,
but if you listen to the things that president Trump has said about the wall
since coming into office,
maybe 2000 miles of wall, that you just don't need that because of nature,
because of mountains and rivers and lots of other things,
it would end up just being a sort of even stronger version of this policy.
Large areas where you don't need a wall because you have a bat and you have a
river, you have a pilot river, and you don't need it,
an even stronger funnel into these very places that are killing people and
you're racing any evidence of their death.
[inaudible]
this episode of our border trilogy was reported by lots of Nasser with Tracy
Hunt and it was produced by Matt Kielty with Bethel Hop Tay and a lot Nasir,
the third installment of our trilogy where things get a lot more personal is
coming up in our next podcast, so stay tuned for that.
Big thanks to Jason Delyon, whose book is called the land of open graves.
And two Timothy Dunn Who's written a lot about this, including book blockading,
the Border and human rights special thanks to uh, Oscar Cervantes,
Jose Romero, Erika King, Joe Reyes,
and the rest of the agents that we met from us,
border patrol in El Paso and to David Ham and Liz and the rest of the staff at
the Border Patrol History Museum and to Veronica Reyes seam trum and two former
El Paso Mayor Larry FrancisFrancis' retired border patrol sector chief Ron
Sanders and Robin Ryan at Kolibri Center for human rights.
I'm Chad Ab and Ron. I'm Robert Krulwich. Thanks for listening.